all right what in the world is this
oh yeah party
party someone's birthday party today and
it's not
it's not it's not you whose birthday can
it be
[Music]
it's the monkey dude's birthday today
look how big those balloons are
whoa look at that
whoa
you big CUNY
it's Mario themed birthday hey don't hit
it either yeah you ninja so we got so
Super Mario right here
we got the Super Mario balloons
we're gonna where are we gonna have your
birthday party today
it's like a Sky Zone equivalent
um and like 20 of his classmates or like
15 of his classmates are coming it's a
big thing but right now I just finished
picking up the cake yeah show me a taika
wanted this cake
you picked it mister you got good taste
do you see Donkey Kong
us
no thanks what you ready monkey man
do you want to be on this side so you
can see oh you want to see his reaction
yeah how does his reaction we see the
first all right
hold on I gotta cut this
be careful I know I've never had a cake
this good in my life
sorry Mom can I catch up no no no no
don't touch it move please
no no these are toys
that is so cool I was about to say a
grown-up word yep don't don't do it
so I saw this um this Korean cake
decorator yeah and I was like I want
this one but that one was only a
one-tier kick and we have to serve like
for 50 people and they had actual
figurines or I assume so so then I went
on Amazon I'm like and I found the cake
artist here and I was like hey can you
throw real figurines on there uh she's
like sure can this is one of the things
I wanted and all the candy and stuff
that was her own touch
so you know it makes me so happy
taika is about to have the best birthday
ever for multiple reasons one anything
that you plan when like you're five and
under their brains aren't all there so
like remember the time we took them to
Disneyland when he was like eight months
old he's just like doesn't even know
what's going on even at his second or
30th birthday he kind of gets what fun
is but not really doesn't have his
choices this year he's like I want Super
Mario I want to be in a trampoline I
want my friends to come so like once
they know what they want then when you
deliver that it makes them feel so good
right and as you guys know watching on
JK news you guys know I never really had
birthdays I spent my birthdays on my
knees because it's the day that I give
things that my mom gave birth to me so I
serve her the entire day so I never had
the American birthday yeah that all my
other friends had and so to see my bear
the woman of the hour put all of this
together like this took
I think like two weeks worth of planning
this was like planning an anniversary I
don't think any of our marriage
anniversaries like ever even been this
extravagant no because you're the one
that's supposed to plan I'm I'm the man
your support the woman supposed to plan
everything I hate you hate you so the
fact that she planned all this is to
give him the best birthday that I never
had makes me so happy
well guess what I'm gonna give it to you
good because you earned it
and also all the other buddies that come
get a bunch of like good doggy bags too
or are they called doggie bags I don't
even know what they're called goodie
bags
so mother is rearranging the fridge
right now so we can put this giant cake
in there so she has to do some Tetris
action and the oven's beeping like a
mofo because we have a lot of guests
coming I think it's about 40 or 50.
um so we bought extra food just in case
the pizza doesn't cut in my bear bought
extra food the lasagna smells delicious
yeah we got lasagna mac and cheese
chicken alfredo from Costco
those taste super good
look at what we had to do to make this
freaking cake fit
we have to take out uh two layers of
this glass which I don't even know how
to do it until today but there's these
little things that you just pop off and
then the base is so big we have to take
off one of these shelves and we just
found out you pop this off and this
thing actually slides down so it was
actually convenient but because of this
fridge I mean because of the cake I
learned about our fridge about our
fridge which is kind of cool but that
thing is huge I even bust out the
measuring tape to make sure to clear
because I don't want to Ballpark it and
like accidentally Nick the top or scrape
something off and that cake is 26 inches
tall
is that crazy
yeah the family's here
what are you guys doing guys playing
[Music]
Derek hey all three of you guys are
pajamas that's cute
when I was practicing practices
all right since we got a ton of people
coming we got to make sure all the
drinks are good so I just went to the
store bought nine bags of ice so that
the drinks would be cold I think two
coolers should probably be enough so I
just gotta I love getting laughter
inside I don't even know what's going on
in there
but yeah so it's Gotta empty these guys
and then put the drinks
and we're good to go oh boy
hey taika
taika they brought you a really special
gift
a really special one
from Theo and Pia you want to see no no
go back go back I'll just give up the
shots you ready yeah
yeah
you're so rude that's what I was saying
that I was telling them to wrap it too
thank you
what are you kidding me they brought it
all the way from La dude
bad boy you bad boy
are you trying to go in the cage you
crazy guy
Oh I thought I thought you're trying to
go in the cage all right so this whole
thing is a setup we got the balloons we
got the giant cake
we have the food we got my bear with all
the snacks
out there
we got two things with the drinks we've
got to surprise those things
and then we also got the goodie bags
this thing is a whole operation
drink cups mixing bowls
thank God we have an extra car today
because I dropped off my car this
morning
um to get oil change but don't blame it
on me because I did ask my bear
yesterday I was like hey can I get an
oil change because I need to drive
Precious Cargo back
to La next week which is Jill's mom and
I don't want anything to happen during
that ride so I was able to get it tuned
up she was like no go ahead says okay
and then this morning she's like oh [__]
I need your truck and I'm like oh [__]
you're right so I'm waiting for the Uber
to come
we do have birthday shirts so bottom is
birthday outfit
but top I'm just gonna sweat in this
because I have a feeling I'm gonna move
around like crazy so I don't want to
sweat in the birthday shirt
just yet me and Mama have matching Super
Mario shirts that one right there
yeah old school
game I used to play would look like this
it's CUNY
[Music]
so I'm a little bit late because I had
to go get my car from the oil change and
also I have to go back to pack the car
full of drinks I just dropped off all
the car I mean all the drinks but we are
at flip out extreme it's like a
trampoline park out here in Summerlin
let's go catch up with the little dude
and see how he's doing
eventually when you walk in is what you
see they're over there
I see some Usual Suspects
see I see inside the mic
see JP over there jumping on the fake
trampoline
where is he
where's the monkey man
Hey
where's the monkey man whoa huh where's
the monkey man
around somewhere oh he's gone okay
oh it's a nice setup we got pasta
it's got cookies
charcuterie board
wow well that's a lot of cookies right
there
I found him
taika
psycho what are you doing up there
taika happy birthday
how'd you get all the way up there this
guy's a monkey mask are you scared just
let go hey monkey just let go he's so
scared monkey
monkey just let go and slide there you
go
hey Erica
that's like his wife were you scared up
there
no
oh asking all his buddies I just want to
say I think he did a really good job
setting up their birthday you know who's
the MVP my brother and my sister-in-law
right now why because I've been going
this and my sister's wall I got it
because she like throws parties all the
time and they're just like party Pros
I'm always like
there's a racist joke right there
stop it because you know Mexicans of the
party all right hey
[Applause]
bro hyper nice to meet you nice to see
you
Super Mario plate Super Mario napkins
even the decorations you killed that
Mama all the decorations are so good
thank you did I kill it on packing the
drinks or what yeah I put water in one
and then uh yeah I'll wait for another
one yeah yeah other coolers all water
okay
my mom wants soda okay Mama you're the
woman of the hour because there's a
million things going on there's a bunch
of parents of names I don't even know I
just know the kids names
so now that we're back here you're
saying how your sister-in-law and your
family's been helping out like crazy oh
my God but this is such a good turnout I
think look at look at all the the way
it's decorated I know appreciate it or
not even care I don't know I mean I'm
sure because he's not even here he
doesn't want to eat and he's like
running around somewhere I don't know
with who let's hope we get our son back
yeah I don't know where he is I feel
like such a
careless parent and that's not me but
he's somewhere
you know what the [__]
there he is
hey birthday boy
what's going on
do you like it
all right it's done but yeah
um
hey monkey come here I want to talk to
you monkey man
do you like this birthday
do you want to do this again next year
yeah okay better tell everybody thank
you so much for coming okay because
everyone's here look at look at
everybody's here just for you just for
you isn't that crazy bones so many
people care about you
you know what's funny uh
you know what's funny it's such a
[__] dick move because I'm the kid
invites their kid friends right so
they're like yay and then the kids
bounce and now you're stuck with two
awkward parents like hey I don't even
know your name that's what I've been
noticing is the uh yeah you just kind of
have to like shoot a little bit and
we're introverted parents like I know
God I'm dying yeah my voice I talk so
little that my voice is strained and I
think I've only been here not even an
hour but my voice is straight
louder
oh
one two
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear tiger
happy birthday to you foreign
[Applause]
wow
okay Erica excuse me okay
hey mama is this red velvet I don't know
yes I think so I think you picked raval
because that's Michael's favorite it is
wow you're a good Mama thank you no not
on accident of course oh there's sticks
I couldn't even tell what flavor that
was
these testers did let me know how it
tastes yeah these are the real ones you
guys you guys know how is it
well it's actually insane yeah it's
really really good nice what is that
that's actually really good which one I
think it's red velvet yeah like a
custard
oh the cream and the custard maybe the
cake itself is a little moist yeah
that's actually good okay
oh we got a little rock climber
right here
are you excited mister
a little bit nervous you got this
before I don't think so this is our
first time
oh you're badass
oh did I say a bad word yeah okay sorry
that's my mom what do you do the second
time I'll go grab your mom so your goal
get all the way up there and press that
gray button push the gray button okay
this stuff
yeah go
good job dude
oh wow
whoa that is pretty tall
[Applause]
good job
you gotta use that one that one right
there
that went out halfway
put your foot on that one yep put your
foot on that one is it slippery
put your foot on it
you're stuck you gotta put your foot on
that
so Taiko wants to show you something
let's go
you could do it there you go good job
there you go good job oh whoa
yup there you go now you want to make
sure you put your right leg
squeeze your right leg over there yep
scoot it over
yep good job now reach reach you can do
it there you go yep smart
yeah you could do it switch your feet
switch your feet on that one yeah put
your left foot yeah there you go there
you go oh good job Mister Good job yeah
just like a little pull up
Hold On Tight Hold On Tight hold on
tight
there you go put your feet
[Music]
this is cool
that's really cool
okay Dominic let me see your best jumps
let's go
oh nice flip let's do your best jump
kaika
oh that's crazy
that's pretty cool
you gonna do it again
whoa
all right so party's over at the
trampoline park heading back over to the
house
but we're still trying to save some of
the decorations look how many balloons
are here these balloons are freaking
crazy
the big six
can't even fit in the camera
so Uncle nads got taika the best gift
ever no I'm not ready to swim don't
squirt at me
at the remote control shark
really I wanted to try it no I wanted a
girlfriend I thought it would be cool
yeah he loves shark he likes megalodons
it looks really good I think it busted
360 or 180.
whoa that's pretty good oh [__] Tokyo
Drift
is the water even warm in there in the
hot tub
e no right right it's cold
hey you go anywhere you want just let
you know it's deep on this side okay you
could you can go up to here
no it's bad
okay so it's morning time day after
taika's birthday it's like I just woke
up what's the first thing you want to do
dude
he wants to open up some of his presents
from his friends that came to visit him
go for it dude
we got dogs
[Music]
what is it what is it
oh cool
thank you
awesome okay you ready for the next one
we play okay so we're gonna open up
another one but what I would like to
stress is that I look at every single
present who gave it to us what they gave
us so that we can
um make thank you cards for the present
that they gave you because you know why
why because people don't have to give
you a present and when they give you a
present you know what they're doing
being kind they're being very kind but
they spend their money and their time on
you don't look at that guy this guy's
look at his butt no he's not it's
licking his knee look
you're just scratching himself okay so
this will be the last person you open on
camera
um because I gotta take notes and I
don't want to drag you along to the
whole process okay let's go
[Music]
oh
really let's see
okay just open the whole thing
and I respect his parents for using what
appears to be Christmas paper
clutch use what you got don't go out of
your way
whoa
our blinds are going oh look at this
let's see this yeah oh double-sided
super clutch wrapping paper
oh very cool dude
what a lucky boy
oh Cooper's like I could chew on that
super cool dude
all right so I'm gonna let this boy open
up the rest of his presents I'm gonna
continue to take notes so I can make
thank you cards to all the parents
um holy crap is it cold in here or is it
hot outside or what's happening Vegas
we've been we've been going through
monsoon season out here
screaming but it's still very hot okay
guys thank you so much for tuning in
we'll see you guys next time
thank you